If there’s two things I know about the universe
it’s that it’s big and there’s a lot
of it.
So much in fact, that we didn’t know where
half of it was until recently.
Now before you get your hopes up, I’m not
talking about dark matter or dark energy,
which combined make up over 95% of the universe.
I know you’re all as antsy as I am to find
out what dark matter and dark energy really
are, but that mystery remains unsolved.
No I’m talking about plain old baryonic
matter like you and me and everything we know.
The stuff that makes up less than 5% of the
universe.
Turns out we couldn’t even track half of
THAT stuff down.
That’s not to say we didn’t have a pretty
good idea of where it was.
See the matter we could account for was where
you’d expect it to be, bundled up in two
trillion galaxies each with an average of
hundreds of billions of stars across the observable
universe.
In between those galaxies we think are filaments
of dark matter, linking them together in a
mind-breakingly huge cosmic web.
We suspected the gravity of that dark matter
also attracted regular matter too, which had
been turned into plasma after ultraviolet
radiation from early stars separated atoms
from their electrons.
This plasma is what’s known as the WHIM,
or Warm-Hot Intergalactic Medium.
For a long time the problem was we couldn’t
see the WHIM, it was just too hard to detect.
Until two separate teams found it using the
Sunyaev-Zel'dovich effect.
When photons pass through a plasma, they get
shifted to a slightly higher energy level.
The effect is very tiny though, so the teams
took data from hundreds of thousands to a
million pairs of galaxies they figured would
be connected by the WHIM and stacked them
up until the effect was noticeable.
Just like that, they found half the baryonic
matter in the universe, and more evidence
of a dark matter web.
So 5% down, 95% to go.
We’re getting closer, guys!
If you liked this video subscribe so you don’t
miss more cool science matters.
We keep coming up with new ways to look for
dark matter, like with black holes and gravitational
waves!
Check out the deets here.
By the way when we say baryonic matter, technically
electrons don’t count because they’re
leptons, but astronomers lump them in with
protons and neutrons to make things simpler.
Thanks for watching Seeker!